>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, D. C.
>> Hirad Dinavari: On behalf of
the library, I quickly wanted
to take a minute to
give my condolences
to all the Iranian women,
Persian-speaking audiences
in Afghanistan, Tajikistan
and elsewhere for the passing
of the poetess Simin Behbahani.
It is with a heavy heart that
I say this in the exhibition.
We have selected a whole section
on women who do Persian Poetry
and Persian language works from
Iran, Afghanistan and Tajikistan.
Simin is one of the
most important poetesses
of the current time,
the Lioness of Iran.
And known as the national
poet of Iran.
Dr. Billington and maybe Jane
when they visited Iran
in 2004 met with her.
She was gracious enough
to give her time.
And it is a matter of great
sadness to us all to see her pass.
And with that I'm going to pass
the grand to Dr. Fatemeh Keshavarz
and ask her to introduce
our lovely speaker.
Thank you very much.
There you go.
>> Fatemeh Keshavarz:
Farzaneh and I go way back.
There has been no particularly
important turning point in my life
in which he hasn't been involved,
whether it was being out for tenure
or getting promoted or you know,
going from institution
to institution.
To actually reading each other's
work and also reading my manuscript
and always being a wonderful
reader and supporter.
So it is with special
pleasure that I introduce.
Farzaneh did a Ph. D in
comparative literature in University
of California, UCLA,
and I believe she worked
with Amin Benoni [spelling assumed].
I also know she worked closely
with many other scholars including
Ishmat Moyedin [spelling assumed]
and others.
But I believe that Amin
Benoni was crucial.
And we do indeed miss him.
He's been a really important voice
in criticism and particularly
poetry.
And in her thesis, Fazaneh
worked on Forough Farrokhzhad
from the feminist perspective.
So this has been a topic
that's been very close
to her heart for a very long time.
She's written close to 100
if not more I'm sure articles
and book chapters and op-eds and
just contributions that just range
from highly specialized
and scholarly to things
that would appear in New York
Times or Washington Post.
And do that very important
job of reaching
out to the broader
interested public.
Her first book, her first
major book actually in English,
Veils and Words is a classic.
It's about wars that
women poets and writers,
their journey within the Persian
culture and you know from 17, 18,
19th century to the present time.
And her latest book, which I
believe came out in 2011, yes,
Words Not Swords, takes that
another step forward on what it is
that women and women's
literature, and looking at it
from a gendered lens does to
understand the role of these voices,
rather than considering
them silent or censored.
So that has been a
tremendous contribution.
I believe you're working
on a biography of Forough,
so we are eagerly looking
forward to that and with
that I'm just going
to invite Fazaneh.
Please join me in giving
her a very warm welcome.
[ Applause ]
Farzanah Milani: Thank you for
taking the time in the middle
of a beautiful Wednesday
to come and hear
about Forough Farrokhzhad
and to listen to me.
You honor me with your presence.
Thank you again.
I'm humbled to talk in the
presence of some giants
in this field of modern literature.
I have my colleague Anna
Corinna Cook [spelling assumed]
for whose work I have
great admiration.
I've written about it.
So it's not only now that I say it.
And of course my dear
friend Fatemeh Keshavarz
from whom I have learned
a great deal.
And the rest of you for being here.
With your permission I would like
to start with a short tribute
to a woman I love like a mother.
To a poet I admired greatly.
I think Iran and all of us Iranians
have lost an enlightened voice
of conscience, an elegant
voice of moderation,
an audacious voice of dissent.
I really think she's irreplaceable.
And there aren't too
many things in the world
that I think are irreplaceable.
Samin Behbahani is irreplaceable.
I hope her words and her advocacy
for nonviolence, which is central
to her work, will spread
to the four corners
of this troubled world we live in.
[ Music ]
Naturally, even though our
government didn't announce much the
passing of this giant of Persian
literature, you saw all the people
of Iran pay tribute to their poet.
In fact, they sang her poems
and these were her own words put
to music by one of our best
singers, Homayoun Shajarian.
And you saw him.
He was at the funeral crying.
Let's switch now to
Forough Farrokhzhad.
I will tell you a little bit
about my involvement
with Forough later on.
But let me tell you
what I plan to do today.
As Fatemeh mentioned, I've been
working on Forough Farrokhzhad
for 37 years and I am finally
finishing her biography.
So it was really hard to condense
it in 45 minutes, in 50 minutes.
So I had to make certain decisions.
So I'm going to focus first
and foremost on the biography
of this iconoclastic icon.
It's amazing that this woman
who chose the penname Iconoclastic
[inaudible] has herself become a
poet, an icon.
But because there is so little
information about the first part
of her life, we know a lot more
about the last 18 years of her life.
In my talk I will focus on
that part and I think most
of that information
has not been available.
And then in the Q&A
I will be honored
to answer any questions you have
about the second part of her life.
I want to tell you a little bit
about the trials and tribulations
of writing a biography in Iran.
Of writing a woman's
biography in Iran.
And in particular in writing
Forough Farrokhzhad's biography.
I believe she is the most
talked-about Iranian woman.
I Googled her about a month ago.
I was going to do it last night.
I didn't get a chance
to be up to date.
But a month ago if you do a Scholar
Google, Forough Farrokhzhad has
about twice as many hits
as Mohammad Reza Pahlavi
who ruled Iran for 37 years.
So it would be fair to say that
she has become quite popular
and she's talked about.
And finally I would like
to share with you some
of her unpublished letters
that I have collected
over the last 37 years.
And that it had taken me
so long to finally decide
that maybe I'm not invading
her privacy to publish them.
I have been in possession
of some of these letters,
not all of them, for a long time.
But because they were so personal,
I wasn't sure it's the
right thing to publish them.
But given the fact that there is
so much misinformation about her.
There is the fact that it's almost
a half a century after her death.
I thought maybe it would be the
right thing to publish this,
about 100 pages of unpublished
letters along with the biography.
So what do we know about
Farrokhzhad's early life?
You have probably as her
birthday January of 1935.
It's not the right birthday.
There is so many misinformation
about her.
And I'm not sure I can figure
out why, but they're out there.
I have seen her birth certificate.
So with certainty I can
tell you that she was born
on Saturday the 29th
of December 1934.
She was born to Turan Vezitabar
and Muhammad Farrokhzhad
Aroki [assumed spelling].
You will see again in Farrokhzhad's
document her name is Forough
Kazemoni Farrokhzhad
Aroki [assumed spelling].
That's her birth certificate.
And I will get to why Aroki,
where does that come from.
The child was born Forough
Kosimon [assumes spelling],
which significantly
means eternal light.
And of course the occasion
of the birth
of a child is always
a jubilant occasion.
And hers was too.
Except that it was marred by
the absence of the father.
Lieutenant Muhammed Farrokhzhad
at the time was in prison.
And he was the head of Pahlavi
royal properties, [inaudible].
And for some reason he and a few
others had been put in prison.
So when Forough was
born, he was not there
to welcome his daughter
who was his third child.
So Mr. Farrokhzhad was released
from prison after a year.
And like the paradoxical
country that Iran is,
after a year of imprisonment he
returned to his position in Yoshat
as the head of the Pahlavi property.
So Farrokhzhad was born in Tehran
but she spent the first six years
of her life not in Tehran but in
Nowshahr, which is the northern part
of Tehran in the province
of Mazandaran.
They lived in a beautiful big house.
In fact, in front of the
castle of [inaudible].
On one side was a forest.
On the other side was
the Caspian Sea.
And Forough loved the forest.
And apparently she was constantly
running through the forest.
What we might not know and
I didn't know for a while is
that Forough was stunningly
beautiful as a baby, as a girl.
She had fair complexion, big
black eyes and curly hair.
Blond, curly hair.
Kind of unusual for Iran.
And lovingly and I would say
ironically she was called
Out of Sight Fradanki.
Now I say ironically because this
little girl was anything but a doll.
She refused to be commandeered
by strings like a marionette.
Throughout her life and beginning
from her very early childhood,
the prospect of becoming
a puppet horrified her.
She had a will of her own.
She was willful, determined,
tenacious.
I will tell you, I have interviewed
over 60 people, her family members,
her close friends and
some of her colleagues.
And most of the information
I give you today are things
that I have cross-referenced.
I've heard some things, if they
were not cross-referenced I've tried
to avoid saying them.
But almost any people who knew her
as a child told me that first of all
when they were in Nowshahr
she preferred the forest.
And when they moved to Tehran
when she was six years old,
she preferred the street.
She was constantly fighting boys
and often gave them a good beating.
She scaled walls.
I've heard from a couple of people
that she was like little
[inaudible].
Agile like a cat.
Really nimble with
gravity-defying agility.
She jumped.
She climbed trees.
This is not image of a young
girl in Iran of the '30's.
She was fearless and daring.
And these words basically
didn't exist in her lexicon.
A little bit about
Forough's parents,
because they in their own right
are really fascinating people
and we don't hear about them.
In particular, we barely
every hear about the mother
who was a fascinating woman.
She too was a subversive woman.
She was born in 1913.
She was unveiled before
the Underling Act of 1936.
She went to the American
school in Tehran.
She was not yet 16 when
at a party in the house
of her relative she met this young
Lieutenant Mohammed Farrokhzhad
who was 11 years older.
She fell in love with him
and he fell in love with her.
Turan had lost her father
before she was even born.
Her mother, lovely mother, and in
fact Forough has a few references
to her grandmother in her poetry.
And the more I've learned about
[Foreign name], the more I have come
to appreciate those lines about the
grandmother in Forough's poetry.
Both of them were very
opposed to this wedding.
But she was adamant she
wanted to marry him.
And they did.
Turan was a very hardworking woman.
Everybody talks about her proclivity
for outspoken simplicity
and honesty.
She had a hard time lying,
as her daughter will later.
I think one of the most
beautiful characteristics
of Forough Farrakhzhad
is her incapacity to lie.
I'm not saying she never lied.
Such a person probably
doesn't exist.
But in a culture of walls and
veils and masks and masquerades,
Forough Farrakhzhad was herself
as much as it was possible to be.
Once she was chosen as
the mother of the year.
This is her.
This is before the age of 24.
She had already four children.
And by the age of 35
she had seven children.
And she had a few pregnancies
that did not go to full term.
Now what about the father?
Let me tell you one
other thing that I find
so fascinating about
Turan Farrakhzhad.
She was a doll collector.
And because dolls are so
central again in Forough's life
and in Forough's poetry, one
of her most beautiful
poems is [foreign words],
"One Can Be Like a Doll."
To say, "Oh yes, I'm so very
lucky all the time," and be full
of pretenses all the time
-- she didn't like that.
Turan Farrakhzhad was a doll
collector and she wanted
to be buried with her
favorite dolls.
Unfortunately, due to
the laws of the land,
she was not granted
this last wish of hers.
I have seen some of her dolls
and when they told me this
story it made me really sad
that they wouldn't even
allow her to do that.
But her dolls were very
important in her life.
You would think after
seven children -- yeah.
Now just a little bit
about the father.
Muhammad Farrokhzhad Aroki,
he was a self-made man.
His last name actually was Rezohi.
And when he was in prison earlier,
he had had a few experiences
in prison, he was reading
Persian literature, poetry.
He loved Persian poetry.
And he came across the word
Farrokhzhad and loved it.
So he decided to change
his last name.
So he changed it from
Rezohi to Farrokhzhad.
And because he was from Tajrish
in northern Iran and at the time
in pre-Islamic Iran
Tajrish was called Araq.
Some called it Arap Ijam.
And then later on it
was called Araq.
So you see in legal
documents, and I've seen --
at the beginning I would
see all these documents
about Forough Farrokhzhad,
Forough Farrokhzhad Aroki.
What is this Aroki coming from?
So that's where it comes from.
And later on of course
it was deleted
and rarely anybody knows
them as Farrokhzhad Aroki.
But all their documents, and I
have seen many of them, the father,
the mother -- in all
of them it's Aroki.
They have that.
So he was 14 when he was going to
marry the widowed sister according
to the customs of Tajrish.
The brother had passed
away and he was
to marry the wife, the widowed wife.
So the day of the wedding
he decided to flee,
to leave Tajrish and
to go to Tehran.
He did so.
He went to Tehran with
very little cash
but an abundant supply
of energy and audacity.
He was a very adventurous man,
audacious is the right word.
He joined Reza Han.
At the time Reza Shah
was not Reza Shah yet.
He joined Reza Han's
Cossack Brigade.
And then when Reza Han became Reza
Shah, soon he sent him to Nushsash
as the head of his properties.
That's how they ended in Nushash.
The first granddaughter --
I'm sorry, the first daughter,
was born in Nushash actually.
After the abdication
time of Reza Shah,
the family moved back to Tehran.
He joined Dejan Darmari
and he changed a few jobs.
And then around the
revolution he retired.
He stayed home and he died
in 1992 at the age of 90.
Now what about Forough?
So at the age of six
they come back to Tehran.
She first goes to [inaudible],
kindergarten.
And then to Sarush,
educational elementary school,
which is a good educational school.
It is interesting.
At the time there weren't too
many coeducational schools.
But that was a coeducational school
in their neighborhood
in [inaudible].
That's where they lived.
Then she goes to [inaudible]
and eventually she decides to go
to a technical school
for her high school.
Because she was interested
in painting and sewing.
Before finishing high school she
fell madly in love with a neighbor,
literally door-to-door
neighbor who happened
to also be a distant relative,
a distant cousin of her mother.
His name was Parviz Shapour.
The parents were adamantly
opposed to the marriage,
but Forough attempted her first
suicide at that tender age.
She was absolutely adamant that
that's the man she wants to marry.
Eventually, on September
14th, 1950 they got married.
Three or four months
earlier, the sister,
Puran had also been
married in the same house.
Forough's marriage from all
accounts was quite different.
It was very simple.
There are absolutely no
pictures of that wedding
because they wanted to save money.
That was not an extravagant wedding.
It was only for tea and sweets,
which usually is unusual in Iran.
The bride did not have her own gown.
She borrowed the gown of her sister.
She borrowed the ring, the
emerald ring of her sister.
Even the mirror and the
candleholders belonged to Puran.
So this is one of the
earliest pictures that we have
of the bride and the groom.
Just to tell you a little bit
about the groom, Parviz Shapour
who was also significantly 11 years
older than Forough Farrakhzhad,
exactly like the age difference
between the father and the mother.
And throughout her life Forough
Farrakhzhad was consistently more
interested in men who were older.
11, Mr. [Foreign name]
is even older.
I will talk in a minute
about Nasir Hodajaj.
He was even older.
So she was interested in older men.
Shapour was born in 1923.
He graduated from Tehran University.
His field was economics and he was
working at the time of the wedding
in the ministry of
finance in Tehran.
Soon after the wedding, the
couple moved to [Foreign name],
which is a southern part of Iran.
Parviz Shapour was an artist.
He was what [Foreign name] called
[Foreign words], which is a fusion
of caricature, airborne drawings
and dexterity with words.
In fact, many people have told me
one of the main reasons Forough fell
in love with him was because
he was so wonderful with words.
And if you read his books and
his [inaudible] you see that it's
with perfect economy, and he
really says a lot in those.
He was working for Thohir
Magazine for a while.
And his drawings were exhibited
in Tehran twice that I know of.
And recently even in New York.
So you know, he was an
artist in his own right.
Usually many of the
people who have lived
around Forough Farrokhzhad
have been overshadowed
by her iconic by her iconic status.
And I think Parviz
Shapour is one of them.
Their son Kamyar was born
two years, a year and a half
after their wedding
on June 19th, 1952.
The mother was still
a teenage mother.
And he was around two years old
when Forough published her first --
this is Forough before
she had nose surgery.
And when she was still in [Foreign
name], early Forough Farrakhzhad.
This is one of my most
precious pictures.
This is after Kamyar was born.
The man in this corner is Parviz
Shapour and the first woman
on the right is Forough Farrakhzhad.
And this is Forough with Kamyar.
Kamyar was about two.
So when Kamyar was
about two years old,
his mother started publishing poems.
She wanted to publish in magazines
as it was customary at the time.
You start in magazines in journals
and then you graduate
to your own collections.
So you might have heard that
one day she went to the office
of [Foreign name], which
at the time was one
of Iran's most popular magazines.
We're talking about early '50's.
Mr. Mushisi the poet was the person
in charge of the literary page.
And he had never met her.
And unannounced she
knocks at the door
and enters the room of Mr. Mushisi.
She's very nervous.
Mr. Mushisi told us
before he passed away.
Mr. Mushisi was also one
of our major literary figures
and a very kind person.
She's kind of shy and shivering
and her fingers are ink stained.
And in her early life,
Forough always wrote
with ink that was green.
Green ink was the ink
she always used.
So it was green.
So Mushisi didn't know
what she wanted.
And she handed three poems to
Mushisi and said that she would
like him to publish these poems.
Now please consider the audacity
of a woman who is barely 20
who goes unannounced, unknown
to the office of a magazine,
finds her way to the
office of the editor
in chief of the literary section.
And Mushisi looks at the poems and
the first one he sees is called Sin.
It's a beautiful poem,
short poem, 12-line poem.
[ Speaking foreign language ]
"I sinned.
I sinned voluptuously
in the arms of the man
that was fury," and
it goes on and on.
It's a reversal of thousands
of years of Persian literature.
It was always men who
talked about their love
for a woman or a feminized lover.
And here was this woman
singing her love for a man.
It was quite clear that it
was a woman writing for a man.
And Mushidi was quite taken.
She said she had two others
and Mr. Mushidi told her,
"I would need to consult
with my editors."
He said he was concerned about
the safety of the magazine,
about the reaction of the people.
And he consulted the
editorial board.
And most of them wanted
the poem to be published.
They thought it's a good
poem, it's interesting.
It's a novelty.
One person, Mr. [Foreign name],
the editor in chief,
was the most adamant.
He said, [foreign expression],
"Of course.
Publish it."
I don't know, that was
not a good translation.
How would you translate that?
"Sure, let's do it."
Let's do it and get
it over with, exactly.
So as Mushidi said,
[foreign expression],
"We published it, but
it didn't go well."
Because although some people loved
the poem, there were a lot of people
who were totally shocked
and aggravated by this poem.
Love poems, adulterous
relationships,
are a dime a dozen in
Persian literature.
We have plenty of adulterous
women in Persian literature.
So what was it about this
poem that became so scandalous
that brought Forough immediately
to a level of notoriety,
of scandal that was
unheard of before her?
What was in this poem that
shocked and titillated the readers?
Because it really did
titillate a lot of people too.
I have a few suggestions and
I'm sure there are plenty more.
This woman calls herself a sinner.
The poem is called Sin
and she begins with I,
which his very unusual,
an autobiographical
statement for a woman.
In a culture where
autobiographical statements
and life narratives
are not quite allowed.
At least they were not allowed.
Now everybody is writing a memoir.
And my aunt too.
But back then it wasn't like that.
We didn't have biographies
or autobiographies by women.
So the poem starts with I.
"I sinned."
But more importantly, she has
sinned but she is not repentful.
In fact, throughout the poem
she is quite exhilarated.
Something mysterious
has happened to her.
The poem is about the awakening
of a woman to sexuality,
to the joy of physical union.
She has never experienced it
before and she has at this time
and she's writing about it.
So she's talking about it [Foreign
name], but she's also talking
about freedom of expression.
"I committed a sin.
Yes, it is a sin.
But eat your heart out.
I am not repentful.
And I'm going to tell
you all about it."
More importantly, this
adulterous woman, unlike the slew
of adulterous women
in Persian literature,
does not undergo a
religious awakening.
She is not taken to the
right path through marriage.
She does not blame the man,
which is admirable in her poem.
She takes full responsibility
for her act.
Unlike most adulterous
women, and conveniently,
she does not commit suicide.
She does not kill herself.
And she's not killed by some
mysterious disease either.
She stays alive and she's
well and she's going to go on.
So but I think even
more important than all
of these things was the
layout of that first poem.
Look at it.
So this whole piece, most
of it is about her picture.
I mean there are two pictures,
and a biographical stretch.
And if you read the biographical
sketch, it's all about the fact
that this is a married woman.
She has a child who
is two years old.
She has beautiful disheveled hair.
She has beautiful black
eyes that are penetrating.
So the focus is on her body
and on her marital status.
So in other words, whoever wrote
that early piece wanted to make sure
that this woman committed
this pleasurable act of union
with a man who is not her husband.
The layout of the magazine turns a
poem into a testimonial of sorts.
It's almost like a report.
At the time, many Iranian
poets had chosen pseudonyms.
Forough Farrakhzhad
could have done the same.
In fact she did use
pseudonyms, pen names,
later for some of her prose writing.
Two very interesting pen names.
[Foreign name], the Iconoclast, and
[Foreign name], Born of Fairies.
That I know of.
There might be others that
I'm not still aware of.
Forough found herself at the
eye of the gathering storm.
The father, Mr. Farrakhzhad,
was furious with the
publication of this Sin.
And of course the husband
was as well.
I have heard that when this poem
was published, and I don't say
that with joy -- my
heart goes to him --
Mr. Shapour, Parviz
Shapour the husband,
did not leave home for a whole week.
He just could not face the world.
And you understand, in a
culture where the honor
of a man depends on
sexual acts of women.
And to me that's the prison, but
that is nonetheless how it is,
how it was back then and how it
is to a certain extent today.
This is Nasir Quidiar
[spelling assumed].
Not much usually is known about
him, which is interesting.
I will tell you, he is the man
for whom Sin was published.
He is the beloved of Sin.
And I'm not intruding
upon Forough's privacy.
In a minute you will see that.
At the time in the '50's it
became the talk of town in Tehran.
It's often mentioned that Forough
Farrokhzhad published her first
poetry collection when she was 17.
I have not come across any such
poems or poetry collection.
Her first collection
is called Captive.
And it was published in 1955.
Most of the poems in it are in
fact written in 1953 and 1954.
So I don't know how she could have
published Asir when she was 17.
So I think that's a false statement.
Asir was by itself a novelty.
For the first time in
Iranian literary history,
a woman from a non-literary
family was publishing a collection
of poems.
Prior to her, none of the poems,
none of the poetry collections
by our women writers have
been published by people
who were not in literary families.
[Foreign names] and the
list goes on and on.
Significantly, the poem Sin
which brought Forough to fame
and notoriety was excised from Asir.
And apparently the relationship
with Quidiar had gone sour.
So soon Asir became a
highly acclaimed poem
because it was unusual poetry.
It had 44 poems.
And it had an introduction
by Mr. Chafa.
So I asked Mr. Chafa.
I said, "How did you end up
writing this introduction to Asir?"
Again, the story is so important if
you want to put it in the context
of the difficulties women
confronted in becoming writers
or poets in Iran of the time.
So apparently the publisher
had told Forough that in order
for her poetry collection to be
published, they would want her
to have a major writer write an
introduction to the collection.
So one afternoon, as Mr. Chafa told
me, there was a knock at the door.
He goes to open the door and
there is a young woman there
with a book in her hand.
And she introduces herself and Mr.
Chafa immediately recognizes him
because at the time many people,
definitely people in literature knew
of Forough Farrokhzhad,
the poet of Sin.
And she was invited in.
And she tells him, "I'm
here because I want you
to write an introduction to my book.
And that's the reason the
publisher wants you to do that.
Would you consider doing it?"
And Chafa says, "Of
course I will do it."
So that's how Chafa
wrote the introduction.
So Asir was published without
Sin, but significantly also
without an afterword that
Forough had written to it.
And that afterword, if you have not
read it, may I suggest you read it.
It's called Tozi.
It is really a manifesto
for Forough Farrokhzhad.
I don't know why it was excised
and I don't know why it's
not reprinted anywhere.
I will be happy to
send you a copy of it
if anybody is interested in it.
I think we should all read what
a barely 20-year-old woman wrote
about poetry and about women's
lives in Iran at the time.
In Asir and then later in the
[Foreign name], Walls, Rebellion
and Reborn, the other
four collections,
these are the four collections
that Forough published
during her lifetime.
There are a few central themes
that are central to her life.
So I'm going to quickly
try to just enumerate them.
First of course is motherhood.
Farrokhzhad was a teenage
mother and in the letters
that you will see published
in the biography
that hopefully will
be published soon,
the pain of being separated
from her son.
And the love that she had for
her son is really central,
not only to her poetry but also
to all the letters, to
many of the letters.
And in fact, because she
chose poetry as a vocation,
as a profession, she was
denied her right of motherhood.
Fatherhood in Iran is a grant,
is a granted phenomenon.
All you have to do is to contribute
physically to the act of conception.
A mother becomes a mother
with birth of the child,
but to remain a mother
she has to earn that.
Motherhood is not a
right for Iranian women.
Motherhood is a privilege.
And because Forough
Farrokhzhad divorced her husband
and because she chose to be, as she
called it, she constantly said it
in the letters, in the poems,
"I want to become a great poet."
She said that since she was 19.
"I want to become a great poet.
And I can't reconcile
that with a life
of domesticity and
raising children."
But that didn't mean
that she didn't want
to have her instinct
as a mother denied.
So that caused her great
pain as many of you know.
After Mr. Quidiar decided to publish
the detail of his relationship
with Farrokhzhad in a serial
called [Foreign name],
she was considered a
promiscuous woman now,
not only by her own admission but
also by the admission of the lover.
And not only she was divorced, she
was denied custody rights of her son
and eventually visitation
rights with her son.
That pain remained with her
for the rest of her life.
It's interesting to note that before
the Feminine Mystique was published
in the US and before Of Women
Born of [inaudible] was published
in the US, Forough
Farrokhzhad had talked
about both those issues
in her poetry.
In particular her first
two poetry collections
which for some reason is not
considered due recognition in Iran.
Everybody talks about
Reborn and nobody talks
about those three first poems
which are the pain of a woman
who is trying to break
free from these molds
that are imprisoning her.
Again, it's not that she
didn't want to be a mother.
She wanted to reconcile
it with being an artist.
And that right was
not granted to her.
This is a picture of [Foreign name].
So after the publication
of [Foreign name],
Forough attempted another suicide.
She was taken to psychiatric
hospital.
She was hospitalized,
institutionalized for a month.
She was given electric
shock therapy.
And when she left, this is
a picture soon after it.
She decided to leave Iran.
She left Iran on a cargo plane.
And in some of the
letters that you will read
in the published letters you
see how she has to scramble
to get the money to go to Europe.
She wanted to study.
She went to Italy and
then she went to Germany.
She worked while she was in Italy.
She did some dubbing,
she did some sewing.
And after 16 months
she decided to return.
She needed Iran and she needed
the language and the people.
She went back to Iran and of course
not having high education it was
hard to find a job.
So she was introduced
to Galistan Film Studio.
Mr. Galistan, a pioneer of Iranian
cinema and Iranian literature,
hired her as a filing clerk.
So she started her position there
to be economically independent
and to finally have
a room of her own.
She started working there, showing
afterward a very passionate,
lustful, loving relationship
developed between the two.
And for the last eight
years of her life,
Farrokhzhad had a very intense
relationship with Galistan.
As you know, her fourth
poetry collection is dedicated
to EG, Ebrahim Golistan.
Some of the poems in [Foreign name]
I believe are the most beautiful
poems a woman has ever
written about a man.
I often tell Mr. Golistan I
think he's the prince charming
of Persian literature.
No man, to the best of my
knowledge, has been loved
and adulated the way
Mr. Golistan has been
in Persian literature
in Forough's poetry.
Forough started travelling.
Mr. Golistan recognized
that she is highly talented.
She showed interest in film.
And in 1962 she was
sent to a leprosarium.
Bhabubhaki Leprosarium.
In which she made the movie -- I
assume most of you have seen it.
If not, please allow me to
recommend you watch that film.
It's a 22-minute documentary.
It has been considered by many
Iranian and western film critics
as one of the best 10
documentaries made in the world.
And this young woman in her
20's with minimal possibilities
and resources made
this amazing movie.
My introduction to Forough
Farrokhzhad was actually
through that film.
I vividly recall the first
time I saw that film.
Images of disfigured
patients of leprosy.
It was a summer day in Tehran.
The smell of jasmine everywhere.
I remember what I was
wearing, where I was sitting.
Certainly I saw these images on
the screen of the television.
I could neither look at these
images nor could I take my eyes off.
It was the most powerful
visual poetry I have ever seen.
Since then, Forough
Farrokhzhad became my companion.
Her poetry became my
garden, my home.
Every time I go to
it, it's welcoming.
I smell my childhood.
I regain the lost time.
It's beautiful poetry and it
has a special meaning for me.
So I came to this country
in 1967, December of 1967.
I wanted to do my dissertation.
My major was French literature and
I was going to write my dissertation
on Flaubert and his search for the
ideal woman and the perfect words.
My argument was that
neither will be possible
because they don't exist unless
you change your perspective.
But so thanks to Dr. Banani,
my teacher and my mentor,
I switched major again and I decided
to write my dissertation on Forough.
But I was going to write my
dissertation on her biography.
So that's in the '70's.
I went to Iran repeatedly
for my research.
And soon I realized that writing
her biography was impossible.
To give you quickly the reasons why,
many men were all too eager to share
with me their love affair
with Forough Farrokhzhad.
I was not interested in that.
Those who knew the most will
tell me, what's the point
of talking about a dead person?
Many people made fun of me.
So in America they give
a Ph. D for a woman
who barely got her
high school diploma.
And on and on.
I have often told Mr. Golistan,
so I can tell you that.
And when I finally met Mr.
Golistan and started asking him
about Forough Farrokhzhad,
he looked at me.
He said, "Miss Milani, I have
heard you are a good cook."
And I thought he was trying to
compliment me, the idiot that I was.
And I said, "Who told you?"
He said, "Your teacher Dr. Banani
tells me you are a good cook."
And Mr. Banani was a chef.
I said, "If he says it,
maybe I am not a bad cook."
I was still clueless.
He said, "I have a
suggestion for you.
Why don't you write a cookbook?"
So that was the end of my
biographical enterprise.
But I promised myself I
will keep working at it.
And I have for 37 years.
It has been a while, but I
have finally almost done it.
And I will quickly tell you
before I finish where I got
after all these years of
agony and not knowing what
to do, where I found my model.
And how I'm trying
to do this biography.
The film, The House is Black is
the biography of a leprosarium,
at least that's how I see it.
It's about life of
patients in a leprosarium,
a colony where lepers were
ostracized and literally imprisoned.
The way she tells the truth, the
way she doesn't sugarcoat anything.
The way she does not invade
privacy, the way she is devoted
to imparting truth as she
saw it without judging,
without moralizing,
was a lesson to me.
This is a tall order
for any biographer.
And I'm not sure I will succeed.
But I can tell you with certainty
that it has been my model.
You know, I would like to be
revealing but not voyeuristic.
I would like to be
candid, but not judgmental.
I would like to be informative
but respectful of someone
who suffered all her life because
her privacy was not respected.
So that's also the reason that
I have been sitting on some
of these letters for decades.
Because those letter were
not addressed to all of us.
Those letters were
addressed to one person.
And I was not sure, even though
the people that I have come
into contact, the people I have
interviewed, were kind enough,
generous enough to
give me those letters.
And I knew I have to
share it with people,
but I wasn't sure I'm invading.
I'm not invading her privacy.
So finally after seeing that film,
and after seeing what she has done
to leprosy, which is a disease that
we always covered up, I said, "No,
she now belongs to
Iranian literature.
She now belongs to Iran."
And after 50 years, after
so many misinformation
and so much information
and misinformation on her,
we need to hear her own voice.
So these are pictures of the son
she adopted at the leprosarium.
She came back with this son
Hossein Mansouri and again she is
to the best of my knowledge the
first woman who began this idea
of single parenthood
and adopting a child.
These are precious pictures that I
don't think you've ever seen before
of Forough at the leprosarium.
And finally just to give you an
idea of the published letters.
Altogether Forough has published
a little less than 80 letters
that have been published so far.
Most of them were published,
56 letters.
55 to Parviz Shapour
and one to his mother.
So a total of 56 in a
collection [Foreign name],
A Man the First Throb of My
Loving Heart, for her husband.
It is a very interesting,
fascinating book.
And just a few other short poems.
All of these letters have
been censored in a way.
There are words missing, a sentence
missing, a paragraph missing.
I have chosen not to do that.
Not a single word will be
deleted from the 30 letters.
And I'm going to have her
own handwriting side-by-side
with the transcribed version of it
so that you can read for yourself.
As you see, the letters span
from her early teenage years
to the last 15 letters she wrote
from Europe to Mr. Golistan.
And I think they are very
important literary documents.
Thank you very much for listening.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at LOC.gov.